ok è sempre strano quando sai che stai
per iniziare un gameplay che aspettano
tutti da un sacco di tempo
me compreso signori oggi siamo su
resident inoltre porca vacca 2020 è la
madonna preparati sia isolato l'intera
regione centro occidentale che gli stati
uniti
la dedizione madonna la ragazza la
soundtrack di residenti voli mi ha fatto
venire i brividi non so perchè escono le
fondamenta un po comunque come quando la
mia ex mi diceva devo parlarti partiva
in automatico bellissimo ecco questo era
meglio non vedere che schifo questo è il
menses immagino frasi del cibo fra i
mamma mi vedevo l'ora è passato il sacco
e dal remake è un sacco un anno però per
me un sacco mi stavo comunque dicendo
all'inizio che gli avevo giocato al 2 di
residenti volo originale quindi giocare
al remake un po sapevo come sarebbe
andata a finire
io non ho mai giocato altre
ok quello originale non ci ho mai
giocato o una mancanza che ho io non so
non mi è mai capitato di giocarci quindi
la prima volta che gioca residenti
voltre chi quindi io tutte quelle robe
col nemesys non l'ho mai fatto che io
sono frescori e dirigenti vol 2 ma il 3
non ho mai giocato quindi questa per me
è la prima volta proprio per il fatto
che non l'ho mai neanche giocato quindi
anche con l'originale del 3 non ho visto
nulla
completamente niente quindi io non so
niente di quello che ho provato a
giocare non sapevo neanche fossi in
prima persona pensate rai tunes e ray
ewry quindi siamo araco city non è anche
di chi sia protagonista del 3 ragazzi
quindi voglio proprio scoprirmi tutto
non mi spoiler a tema ammazzo paventato
registi giorni quindi all'acqua accesa
proprio la madonna testo è molto meglio
del 2
comunque l'acqua accesa non la lasciamo
perché è uno spreco quindi per cortesia
ovviamente con che questa qua e la
classica e il classico bagno delle
ragazze fidanzate quindi trucchi quindi
la pistola
cosa mi dice che non è proprio il
massimo secondo me medico dovresti
vederlo ok fa niente lasciamo stare il
medico ha sparati no è una che lascia
una che lascia l'acqua aperta di notte
un porselo me dice che non va bene
scherzavo sei bella comunque c'è per me
lo è lo stesso anche da zombie la
limonata ma la prego
ecco bravo è quello il consiglio dato io
quindi ragazzi spero che il vino vi sia
piaciuto a ok
ecco prima roba che hai detto già il
video col bollino giallo
l'abbiamo messo l'acqua si chiude porco
demonio non guardate lo specchio che
prima è successo perché lasciamo aperta
che problemi hai a samolaco aperta si
basa sull'offerta con te stessa cosa c'è
bene che è successo non c'è molto tempo
ma questa stessa chiamata che ha
ricevuto giugno quando
porca [ __ ] salve picchia che sia
successo ma subito ma veramente mi
chiama gioco parte così
ma siamo seri allora io sto male
quindi il gioco parte così con inediti
questo è il nome dato noia
buongiorno corri corri tanto mi come
faceva a saperlo che stava entrando il
meno esiste nella mia stanza ragazzi
chef a cori mi chirurgica è il nemesis
corri scappa c'è lei mesi siano già
detto sì abbiamo fatto benissimo
comunque vorrei tanto sono entrati in
una casa che non era la mia un'altra
come un'altra casa cava porta aperta ma
dai che l'intuizione ci hai avuto via
via via via via non so i tasti non so
niente come faccio cadi cadi zio io c'ho
nemesis pietro vorrei essere io al tuo
posto
forse solo una questione rampi carmi
adesso non lo sapevo lo sapevo lo sapevo
che mi colava il soffitto lo sapevo
c'era rischio messo qualsiasi cosa stavo
per dire porca vacca che mi ricordavano
alla macerata di assassin's creed è
invece la pistola che avevi prima dov'è
finita tra avrà tagliati bravissima meno
male che a me non comando una abbastanza
tosta corriamo da brava guardi anche un
po indietro 6 voglia un paio di volte
devi guardare indietro
l'erba lina lasciamo che se dovrebbe
andare
porca vacca ce la facciamo a shell non
puoi buttarti buttati butta chi si butta
ti sull'ambulanza ci arrivi porca va
bene fa niente
ci voglio credere per i catari fatto
bene a buttarmi sull'ambulanza quid
altro poteva stritolarla potevi fare
quello che volevi aiuto di chi è cascato
il pavimento
non ci credo io non starei troppo
volevo fare orco del demonio porto fuori
cosa faccio c'è un'uscita non puoi
semplicemente a lanciar meloni colpisci
prima gli avrei fatto così l'esperienza
gioca venerdì 13 che l'anci dei contenti
ecco vedi i cazzi tuoi potevi uccidermi
sei un pirla però fa niente ragazzi che
inizino mai mai nella mia vita ho
iniziato un gioco così madonna un attimo
quindi lei gil una retorica di te
dovrebbe saperne di seguito a questa
parte a eccoti salve sono sopravvissuto
a satana sono già gli zombie li mortacci
loro
ragazzi non abbiamo pistole non abbiamo
niente brad dammi qualcosa che è membro
ex membro della starz sei ex ma se in
realtà
corriamo via perfetto fuori alle palle
barjac c'è un bar che fantasia come lo
chiami barge
mi sa che brad finisce ma io li taglierà
il braccio per sicura di tagliare il
braccio tale dalla cia prete ed è morto
se si ammazzano ammazzano siamo ancora
una squadra
certo avrei detto la stessa cosa grazie
prende il tuo sacrificio sarà ben
riposto quindi ma che devi fase fatto
morde colpa sua pistola santo iddio era
meglio se va bene si avvicinato
tranquillamente allo zombie come se
potesse non saltare alla gola
brad subito che è uscito a non è brad ma
io non voglio sparare gli posso dove
posso andare via da risparmi colpi ma
non ho io sono li voglio sparare tanto
di spari ancora attiva affabula tanto lo
so che si spara
ok speriamo non fosse tanaka tonale io
c'ho cinque colpi ragazzi il suo gioco
l'unica cosa che ho capito
l'unica cosa che ho capito e residenti
volo che devi risparmiare i colpi come
se non ci fosse un domani perché se ti
finiscono i colpi ce l'hai nel deretano
io non sparo a nessuno ma ci sono
oggetti che ho dimenticato qua dietro
che non sono state a controllare per
bene ma per chi se ne frega perché a lui
mi sa che gli devo sparare se non entro
salve a voi vi ammazzo ottimo sono un
ottimo tiratore ok a posto ok è andato
giù quello lasci strisciare tanto non ci
arriva lavorasse un primo colpo sparato
a vuoto mi sa che anche i presidenti co2
è stato così primo colpa loro
a posto a posto tranquillo si chiama
giovanni ii mio amico non è pericoloso
sono tre corpi di cui uno nell'acqua
però ottimo secondo me l'elicottero a
finire malissimo
qualcosa mi dice che non
questa il piede il tetto di nel tetto e
sulle macchine a perché un parcheggio
scusate ha dimenticato st piccola è un
parcheggio
salto fila cazzo sono spider man va bene
arrivo scusa che zoppica però è perfetto
non me l'aspettavo per niente proprio
wow che a sorpresa è andato proprio
buongiorno si vede dal mattino
sono le otto quindi figurati
c'è il giornata di merda ecco per affari
guidare non mancava del buongiorno guido
io tra me il nemesis trame con la
macchina e lei mesi se non so chi sia
più pericoloso
questo accende sempre più vicino chi
cazzo detto juncker incredibile come
faccio per guidare passate nel pronto il
tasto sinistro anche nella realtà
fissandosi orca anno tieni premuto c'era
anche scritto cosa devo fare
schiacciatore che tiziano
tutto bene mica se non è morto qua ciao
ovviamente non sarà morto però è però
allegro come gioco e vero quello da
giocare quando sei di utili cattivo
umore ti solleva un po come si risolleva
lui dopo essere stato schiacciato da una
macchina dopo che cade dal terzo piano
sopra di lui però vabbè fa niente
veramente carina lei però più bella cosa
non ti cazzate ma proprio devo fare io
so ciò che lo passa a correre sparagli
sparagli fa qualcosa spara lì
corriamo maron se sei brutto
picazio stato ha bloccato un missile
libia c'è stato e brad non ne brad
madonna che lancia razzi pazzesco lo
presti fratello ai miei stessi capelli
questo ci sono pochissime è arrivato
sono carlos articolo ecco dei capelli
del genere non potevi chiamarti in altro
modo se non carlos mamma mia ragazzi che
vai bellissimo promette da dio sto gioco
anche partito meglio del 2 capitano alla
signorina serviva aiuto ha detto non
possiamo farcela da soli
va bene ci sta faccio io
invece di dar mista cagata puoi darmi la
m4 che mi servirebbe un sacco per favore
polvere da sparo questa cosa combini con
l'altra polvere da sparo ti dà una
scatola di proiettili standard quindi
quella che ciò si si si si
live view molto bene speravo di beccare
cose che ti ampi dall'inventario perché
non lo nego così tanto non ho mai capito
se combinare due piante verdi serve a
qualcosa effettivamente secondo l'ami i
miei ragionamenti non serve un cazzo
perché fai prima a usarne due separate
però magari mi sbaglio io questa è la
cassa procede ficca dentro le robe se
non vuoi perdere 10 cliccare già dentro
questa così tanto in due non credo mi
servono
detto questo esco mi fanno un culo così
però doveva ritrovare delle armi tutto
sto casino con lama ha detto sopra
troverà i rifornimenti
io non ho visto mezzo però fa niente
proiettili ok tanto quell'ora oddio che
minchia pensavo fosse va di qua non ce
l'ho passato prima non era il caso di
primavera sito fa fuori per forza porco
del demonio sono storto come la morte ok
ok maori mori no mi chiamo rischiato
meno male che è morto tre colpi in testa
e moglie non abbiamo appurato questo
allora quando non ce l'ho passato prima
scusa milan o in altro poster simile a
colori prima mischia che krypi
dall'ombra mi sembrava quello che
striscia sono i soffitti non mi viene il
nome verso ei cioè salvini su un poster
michele gaza la difesa del barcellona
che madonna di dio tutti qua davanti
alle scale prima non c'era nessuno tutti
qua che concerto the one direction porca
vacca non è incredibile
vuol dire quando erection 9 sono
abbastanza zoppica bruciato da albano
comunque andiamo avanti
beh però la fico comunque veramente un
gioco fatto da dio
devo trovare delle cose fatte decenti
tipo le armi per cominciare prima che
polvere da sparo bene bene bene bene
perfetto camminiamo con birra bravo
perfetto sono fiero di me stesso
c'è una cassaforte allora questa è una
di quelle che proprio a aa sgamano la
posso mai aprire è impossibile
c'è una possibilità su un miliardo
quindi queste qua sono famoso per aprire
il bello salve
apprezzo anche lei l'arte anch'io
meraviglioso acqua che ora cosmi ci
provo questo è il numero 9 37 e il la
combinazione della del lucchetto 93 79 a
sinistra 3 a destra seta sinistra non ha
ricordato
ai 9 37 proprio lui maestro degli enigmi
mirino ma con mini non pensavo di
trovare le europee molto più [ __ ]
cosa faccio il mirino sulla pistola ma
ci vedevo anche prima cosa me ne faccio
l'idea perché adesso perché ora è
ristretto il mirino quindi proprio
adesso non posso mancare il bersaglio
figo vabbè dai pensavo fosse meno utile
ma ora meno vale io c'ho miglior la
pista perché prima eri orba lanciava
cerminara in testa e quindi dovevo
andare di qua e là un programmino
funziona adesso ce ne vogliono quattro
però di corpi con questa storia porco
demonio ma è lei miss fa vj a evra
mirino che riguarda tu non ti alzare ti
faccio fuori pure la famiglia vabbè lo
sapevo lo sapevo non mi fido neanche di
colori e troverebbe lo dico io ragazzi
porco del demonio come come faccio da ai
ragazzi l'ho saltato lo sapevo lo sapevo
lo sapevo
puoi stare seduto morto sdraiato fai
quello che vuoi
meraviglioso chimica è insostenibile
cosa c'è scritto qua a sono persino
arrivato al punto di compra un fucile
nel caso in cui la situazione l'ho messo
al sicuro nei porta fucili se le cose si
mettono male tagliate la catena usate
quella bellezza
ho capito che come la tagliamo sai mica
scritto dove lasciato la chiave
ovviamente no e io come minchia la
tagliolà catena le cesoie per prendere
il fucile dio sia lodato gesù mi ha
veramente fatto il culo non me
l'aspettavo mai
porca vacca mai abbassare la guardia sto
gioco rega madonna come mai incappato
minchia ci sono entrato tre volte li mai
veramente in chrome non aspettò mai
maori peraltro vero tutto operato mi ha
veramente fregato tantissimo
mamma mia ragazzi bona dai l'importante
che siamo arrivati a caso due ore per
arrivare ai tronchesi figlio di sua
madre
vabbè dai apriamo effetto minchia mi ha
veramente vi sono rimasto scioccato
lucia quindi occupa solo uno slot in
fucile ottimo prova ad alzarti mamma mia
mi ti faccio saltare la vita va bene
sono fucile munito meno male perché mi
serviva tantissimo adesso che si alza
pure questo porca vacca e ce l'ha
passato tre volte non ti azzardare a
rompermi le palle non ti sparano col
fucile che lo vuoi
non so che lo bravi
madonna è chiaro è veramente questo
gioco veramente un'ansia incredibile a
ragazzi io non ho provato tra l'altro a
dar non vorrei farlo però non vorrei ci
fosse qualcosa qua dentro che non ho
visto sempre con le tronchesi da prove
di tronchesi perché qua prima la tipa ma
detto
non c'è qualcuno li dentro quindi non
vorrei proprio aprirla
però se proprio devo magari ci
sblocchiamo una stanza utile perché a
dire che siamo con di vivo chi minchia
voglio che questo di saltare quello solo
in parte
mi piace questa filosofia bravo quale
effetto ma non potevi saperlo
per amor litri e stessi ecco perché
siete quasi tutti molto chi cazzo
foligno bisconti ammazzate tra poi si
sarebbe trasformato ha intenzione di
morire giovane per caso torna subito la
stazione della metro
non abbiamo bisogno di una crocerossina
da queste parti ma spara la gente come
lui si diverte voli
non so perché io sto presentimento raga
ma qua sarà veramente un bel casino
non so cosa che me lo sta dicendo no no
no va bene
che schifo custodia ebbe esami dalla boe
che schifa non arrivai dei ragni quelli
bio stavi dare un attimo un'altra gemma
no
che cacchio è grande
ho trovato il grimaldello per aprire
queste per forza
adesso la pro tutte sicuro di riemann
dello almeno lo apre da sola
pensavo dove si fatti poi skyrim kate
non perché la pista
no io non miro milioni rifiuto io mi
rifiuto non bastava aragno e già va beh
mica potranno mettere farfalle i topi no
ai ragni ok ma pure limonato che schifo
di sicuro devi metterti l'orsetto che
schifo vomita nel buco che non lo fa qua
vomita poi tra l'altro mi avrà ficcato
dentro una di quelle robe schifosissime
tipo alien che mi crescono dentro alla
fine dentro comoglio ecco schifo fai
schifo non si dimora senza aver portato
prima a cena una ragazza e ricordati
pagherai tu comunque tutto ma è un boss
ma se non ho capito se questo non è un
boss è morto troppo in fretta a
parassiti me li tolgo e come me li tolgo
con l'erba io la uso tanto 11 la devo
usare per fare a con l'erba si tolgono i
parassiti e allegro
ora nicchia il fucile usa il fucile che
schifo veramente minchia lo disintegrato
e te lo meriti fai schifo è merda quindi
io devo prendere l'erba per vomitare i
parassiti che schifo e nulla mi dice che
dio li abbia scusi tutti sì me lo dice
qua che scrive d'altro sto ancora
morendo
quindi non è anche fa
ma lo vedi che si può equipaggiare il
coltello ma chi te lo quindi io prima ho
sprecato un colpo per niente ah beh dai
fa niente tanto era uno come ho fatto
qui pagare il coltello
vedi che si può poi kakà non sapevo va
bene lo sapevo aiuto corni e vabbè poi
vai vai vai vai spara bypass tappa e
piccoli quanti minchia siete maledizione
by non voglio rivedere questa zona della
mia vita via via via si sa proprio stare
faccio stabiliti stato il gioco adesso è
fatta lo da sola che cacchio in due ore
di zombie bragno inutili questa mi è
piaciuta brava mi sta simpatica questa
perfetto
che succede quindi se adesso torno lì il
successo un casino va bene quindi torna
stazione metro perfetto ho fatto tutto
ma io pensavo che l'interruttore fosse
quello che avevo trovato nella stanza
vicino al fucile riportate è infatti
quello quello dicevo io dicevo proprio
quello ma cosa zur chiaro ma ben fatto
zucchero al massimo albano tutto sto
casino devo aprire un miliardo di
armadietti le che ha meno male vado
perché io un pochettino me l'aspettavo
solo che non potevo dire niente ma lo
sapevo ha posto sono sto bene per carità
di dio mica mi ha fatto male anzi sono
beccato un pugno in faccia
fa niente minchia
ma allora lento lo zio
ok sono stato bravissimo quoziente
intellettivo 200
ma come lo schivato bene come sono
proprio un membro della star
non voglio stare qua dentro e ho capito
attacca però prima deve ripristinare il
sistema
ok posso andare grazie c'è il polvere da
sparo qua non c'è polvere da sparo sono
anche morendo quindi mi devo prendere
una pianta verde dove andato l'ultimo
magari non è più sotto sta crescendo
ok non è più solo è sparito dove era ma
porca vacca corri devo passare dal
donuts che sta qua a destra mai polvere
da sparo presa colpirà combina combina
perfetto vai da passare dal italy dalida
di corri corri santo iddio a chi tutto
come faccio miracoli
[Musica]
sono riuscito a sparare al kosovo
sparare col non puoi entrare qua puoi
entrare anche qui mica puoi fare quel
cazzo che vuoi tu
ok no non ce la faccio dovuto fare così
per forza non ce la facevo non passavo
ok città metropolitana bye bye bye bye
bye bye bye bye bye cori che c'è satana
in persona che ti segue non ho neanche
preso l'erba sono un deficiente a
quest'ora tira e la saga di contatti ra
un coso qua pure tu madre a rock è
giusto ci siamo viste le cose rosse
pensavo io e sbagliato una tesi tanto è
facile c'è solo chiunque che vi segue un
bar di coach è una cosa che non avevo
vista c'è magari avevo visto che potevo
aprirlo un bazooka regala melo va bene
anche questo cartucce per fucile quanto
la baciò non sono messo male però ok
ragazzi devo arrivare alla m no all'erba
io muoio non c'è una cassa come annuncia
un altro armadietto però dimmi che trovo
delle armati proclami dell'erba e per
chi si va da questa frase
però devi serve dell'erba si va bene lo
stesso lo spray mele di cover del
premier i ragazzi ti frulla
completamente la vita va usato in
non c'era uno zombie prima che avevo
completamente esteso si è alzato il
pezzente
vabbè ci fu la completamente la vita io
lo sapevo che prima o poi non pensavo di
controlli già adesso questi porco
demonio aspetta questa ok ok è morto a
posto
questo sito
allora e mori o santa pace
niente questa ma pure preso mi chiami
ammazzato pisciotta non mai stato ma mi
ha colpito insieme ha colpito mi
sembrava adesso mi fa jump in avanti
potresti correre normalmente qual è il
problema se riesco a schivare nel
momento giusto anche se mi colpisce
teoricamente riuscire a donare a chi è
bruttissima situazione e che devo fare
il problema è il dopo il 3 dopo che è
pieno di gente capitolo cioè minchia
proprio un casino o tiro fuori il fucile
però vabbè tiro fuori dal fucile da
youtube che se non ha veramente
difficile vai 1
devo fare per forza così raga perché ce
ne sono troppi 20 teoricamente cioè di
aver fatto guarda che pirla che sono
stato no minchia che botta in faccia è
tra c'è culo media cosa scherzi si
tranquilla come se stessi chiudendola
negozio alla fine del lavoro senza
problemi intanto non c'è mica belzebù de
fori va bene è stato non vorrei mai più
di fare questa cosa
fammi recuperare vita cosa che c'è tra i
medico mamma mia che ansia e comunque
altre gemme non ne ho trovate perché se
ci muoviamo allora potrò tornare
indietro nella m perché non ho trovato
altre gemme o erano nascoste in altri
armadietti che non ho piu visitato però
aveva niente da andiamo lo stesso
questo è il 4 a dell'erba ho mai dato
mai stato così contento di prendere la
metro nella mia vita
porca vacca che titone sono partiti
senza di me siamo pronti ma ci servono
altri 30 cuore ma si tanto a quelli
primo live nicolai l'accetta brulica di
quelle creature non potremo farci strada
a forzare che ci fai qui c'è tutta far
ripartire il treno non abbiamo bisogno
di pesi morti ma va va un fitto io non
sa quando premere il grilletto la
rivista carlo mazza
devi scusarlo sono stati un po stressati
maledizione ancora non è qualcosa di 30
minuti con gaza ma dobbiamo far fuori
no no no no no la comando io l'ariston
itala comando io raccomando io l'ho
tirato anche un cazzotto o dai del lei
perfetto via via via via via via via via
via via ma io devo correre dove dove
vado non so lei prende iniziativa come
se sapesse dove andare io non so niente
di strano dove vado a spiegare loro gli
do fuoco dove pero dove vado non so dove
andare a c'è un aborto la linea
nicchia e poi tutto sto casino perché
voglio farlo saltare in aria tutto a
posto
chi è caduto qualcosa a mi sa che gli ho
levato la maschera ho capito se vai però
dai veloce dove ha dato madonna rega
perfetto demoniache rappa con i suoi
tentacoli invece no le fogne mancavano
le fogne effettivamente da residenti vol
2 lega let's go
no io me li faccio le fogne ti prego
dimmi che andiamo dall'altra parte con
carlos lavatrice e vive di più con
carlos largo ce l'ho fatta
questa non apre manco lui dai
meravigliosi sicuramente spunterà da
un'altra parte
quindi sono finito nelle fogne quindi
davanti a molte persone
ok che sono tornate alla fogna e quindi
siamo arrivati alle fogne per sé
totalmente un'altra parte torna in
superficie
obiettivo va bene signori spero che il
video vi sia piaciuto che sarà il primo
episodio di recitativo frecce diamo al
prossimo promette da paura è veramente
figo
quindi niente si chiedeva crescita di mi
piace e noi ci vediamo al presidente
come sempre
beh ragazzi
[Musica]